you belong to me
you understand what i'm saying now lift
up that skirt
no
[Music]
seven times in the past 26 months
women have been brutally murdered and
dumped like garbage along interstate 10.
and he's hurting girls right now
we're the fbi what the hell do you want
at my crime scene
we had set up a prostitution sting here
last night i got a 20 year old girl
with a skull cracked his target last
night
do you have a name you can't reopen this
you got to move on nobody's ever stood
up for those girls
headquarters pulled the plug on us i'm
doing nothing tonight
you want to know the truth you're going
to get me killed
he had a bonafide serial killer
white male truck driver mid 30s
who was he he tried to cuff one of my
girls he had a lightning bolt on his
truck
he's gonna want to try again all right
he's moving
away
she promised me this is gonna be bad
i need to do my job
i need to see your cameras who's that
where do they go where does it take
somebody there he's gonna kill you
tonight
do everything you can to get
you out promise me to always walk
through that door
we got the wrong guy
folks now you live alone i just want to
keep an eye out for you
[Music]
hello